Speaker 1: this is super interesting.
We've been talking about declining interest
in vaccination.
The people who already have been vaccinated
are mostly people who really wanted to be
vaccinated.
And now we have a situation where supply is
starting to exceed demand and a government
state governments need to figure out new ways
to get people interested in getting vaccinated
because remember, no matter what anybody tells
you, there's no mandatory vaccination per
governments.
There are certain schools that will say if
you want to come to campus, you have to go
and get a vaccine or if you want to work for
us, you have to go and get a vaccine.
But there are no mandatory vaccinations per
the federal, state or municipal governments.
But you have an interest from governments,
state governments.
They want to be open and they want to be open
in a way where people aren't going to get
sick because that's what's best for business.
So they're thinking of new ways to encourage
people to get vaccinated.
Republican Ohio Gov. Mike DeWine is creating
five one million dollar basically lottery
rewards for people who get vaccinated.
Five people who get vaccinated in Ohio are
going to win a million dollars each.
The Republican governor announced this last
night all vaccinated adults will be eligible
to enter a lottery that will pay out one million
dollars each to five winners starting just
a couple of weeks from today, March 20th,
May 26th, rather.
And separately, DeWine is also offering five
vaccinated teenagers full ride scholarships
to the state's public universities, including
tuition, room, board and textbooks.
The textbooks are key.
Oftentimes you hear free tuition, right?
But what about the thousands of dollars for
textbooks?
It will even include that, DeWine said in
a statewide address, quote, I know some may
say, DeWine, you're crazy.
The million dollar drawing idea of yours is
a waste of money, but truly the real waste
at this point in the pandemic when the vaccine
is readily available to anyone who wants it,
is a life lost to covid-19.
I think that this is absolutely fantastic.
And understand that you have money set aside
already in a number of different states for
vaccination and for getting people vaccinated
and public awareness campaigns.
This is a way of using five million of that
dollars instead of on billboards and TV ads
or whatever the case may be.
You're just saying, well, let's just give
five million plus the cost of tuition to the
five teenagers, to some people.
And I think it's absolutely fantastic.
The lottery payout will be funded using federal
coronavirus relief money allocated to the
states.
States and localities have been given this
money by the Treasury.
They've been given wide discretion about how
to spend it.
And Mike DeWine is saying, let's give it to
some people.
There are questions as to how effective public
health officials think that this is going
to be.
Tara Smith, who teaches epidemiology at Kent
State University, says there's some research
to suggest small financial incentives could
increase vaccine rates, but that just giving
a million dollars to five people may not work
because of the perceived odds of winning are
relatively low.
And that if there is a criticism of it, that
was my thought, which is a million dollars
for five people, that's a lot.
But what about giving one hundred thousand
dollars to 50 people?
It's the same amount of money, but I think
the perceived odds of winning will be higher.
And of course, they will be they would be
10 times higher.
Let's listen to Mike DeWine announcing this
and talking about this yesterday
Speaker 2: on May 26.
We'll announce the winner of a separate drawing
for adults, adults who have received at least
their first dose of the vaccine.
This announcement will occur each Wednesday
for five weeks, and the winner each Wednesday
will receive one million dollars.
Speaker 1: So I think it's a great idea.
Again, the only change I might make is instead
of five people get a million dollars each,
I might make it 50 people get a hundred thousand
dollars.
And the.
The alternative that was also proposed is
just pay everyone who gets the vaccine, figure
out how many people, how many adults you have,
divide up the five million dollar prize pool.
What does it work out to give that to everybody?
And then for the unspoken for money at the
end of the campaign, maybe then that becomes
sort of like a lottery or something like that.
A lot of different ways to do this.
I think it's a I have no moral problems with
it at all.
And if it's effective, I'm 100 percent for
it, let me know your thoughts, let me know
if you would go about it a slightly different
way, and we'll have more coverage of what
different states are doing to encourage vaccination
on our Instagram page, which you can find
at David Pakman show.
You can also find me on Instagram at David
Pakman